weird it's been ten minutes since Justin
said he'd be here in 10 minutes maybe
he's just running late
no does that he loses track of time does
that quite a lot wait did he say be
there in ten or at ten it's 8:00 right
now in my two hours early or did he mean
10 a.m. because in that case I'm 14
hours early or 10 hours late no that's
ridiculous he's coming unless something
bad happened to him what if he choked on
a cashew you know that's his favorite
nut he probably threw one up in the air
and gosh it was my best friend
I'm gonna miss him so so much unless he
met someone and fell in love in that
case the for you maybe you just forgot
about your good old best friend and
you're spending too much time being in
love maybe he just booked tickets to
take his new lover to a sexy getaway to
Havana Cuba he knows that I've been
wanting to go to Havana ever since we
both watched Dirty Dancing to Havana
nights well maybe this is the truman
show you know the 1998 cult classic
about Jim Carrey being the star of a
reality show without even knowing it
living a life of Lies where everyone
surrounded around him as an actor
oh.just is probably late because he's
too busy practicing his lines I'm your
friend
the people here in this bar look at this
bartender here she's not real
she's completely doing everything wrong
she's totally an actress hey I'm on to
you I know you're an actor um so is
everyone else in LA all right
or maybe a short-term memory loss and
he's been trying to hide it from him for
the past couple of years every 20
minutes he has to look at a series of
pictures with titles on them to remind
him who his real friends are maybe he
lost the picture with me on it and I'm
now just a nobody to him Oh traffic
traffic he's in he's in traffic friends
in traffic I'm not here alone he's in
traffic how's the black ting thing
Oh